CHRISTINE BREINER: Welcome
back to recitation.
In this video, I'd like us to
see how geometric methods can
help us understand the flux of
a vector field across a curve.
So in particular,
what we're going to do
is try and use geometric
methods to compute
the flux of four different
vector fields F across curve C.
So I've labeled them
for later purposes.
I've labeled them F_1,
F_2, F_3, and F_4,
and they are as follows.
F sub 1 is the
vector field that is
a scalar function
of only the radius,
times the vector x comma y.
And the curve I'm
interested in in this part
is the unit circle.
The second one, part b, is the
vector field that is g of r--
again, where g is
a scalar function
and r is the radius,
so it depends only
on the radius-- times
the vector minus y, x.
And again the C will
be the unit circle.
The third and fourth ones,
we use a different C,
but they will be the same there.
I'll point that out.
So in the third one,
the vector field
is 3 times the vector [1, 1].
And C in this case will be
the segment connecting (0, 0)
to (1, 1).
So it's a piece of
the line y equals x.
And then in part d, F will be
3 times the vector [-1, 1].
And C is, again, this segment
from (0, 0) to (1, 1).
So again, what I'd like you
to do is rather than trying
to parametrize the curve and
do the entire calculation,
I'd like to see you
try and understand
the relationship between
each of these vector fields
F and the normal to the
curve that they're on,
and see if you can
figure out the flux based
on that relationship.
So why don't you pause the
video, give that a shot,
and then when you're
ready to see how I did it,
you can bring the video back up.
OK, welcome back.
Again, I'm going to try and
use my geometric intuition
to understand what the flux is
for each of these four vector
fields along these four curves.
So what I'd like to do is, if
I'm going to try and understand
geometrically what's
happening, it's
always good to draw a picture.
So I'm going to draw a picture
that I'll use for a and b,
and then I'll draw
another picture later
that I'll use for c and d.
So notice again in a, my
curve is the unit circle.
And I have a somewhat
explicit understanding
of what the vector fields are.
So I'm going to
draw the unit circle
and see if I can figure
out where F_1 and F_2 are.
It's not a perfect unit
circle, but it looks sort of
like the unit circle.
So this is going to
be my unit circle.
And what I want
to point out first
is that I was not
trying to trick you,
but just to help you
notice, that in a and b,
they both depended on
this radial function.
But the radius on the
unit circle is fixed at 1.
So in both of these
vector fields,
it will simply be g of 1.
So that will be
a constant value.
So all that's giving me is some
scalar multiple of whatever
the length of this one is.
So it's this direction
times this scalar g of 1.
One other thing I
want to point out
is that both of these
vectors, F_1 and F_2,
if I ignore the g part, and
I look at just the x comma
y and the minus y comma x, is
these parts have unit length.
And you should be able to see
that right away, because x
and y are on the unit circle.
And so the length of
the vector whose tail
is at the origin and head is
on the edge of the unit circle
has length 1.
And then you can easily see
that this vector and this vector
have the same length, because
their individual components are
the same absolute value.
We already understand a few
things about F_1 and F_2
right away.
That all the length
is coming from this g,
and g is fixed all the
way around the unit circle
at g of 1.
Now let's figure out what the
flux is for these two things.
So if you notice first, F
sub 1 is the vector [x, y]
times the scalar g of 1.
So if I come over here,
I want to point out--
I'll do this part
in white first--
that if I'm at this point--
this is the point (x, y)--
the vector [x, y] is
equal to this vector.
So if I think about putting
that at this point--
I'm going to draw
it here-- I get
something that looks like this.
So this is F sub 1, probably.
I'm going to have to make
one comment about that.
But notice, this should look
like it's all in one direction.
So this is the vector [x, y].
If I slide it so
its tail is here,
it's again in the
same direction,
and now I've just
scaled it by g of 1.
Now, this is assuming,
obviously, that g of 1
is positive.
So we're going to assume
that throughout this problem.
I'll mention what happens
when g is negative at the end.
So this is my vector F sub 1.
Let's think about what is
the normal to this curve.
The normal to this
curve, actually
at each point on
the circle, points
in exactly the same
direction as F sub 1.
Because if I'm parametrizing
in this direction,
the normal-- I'll
draw one down here
so we can see what it looks
like-- the normal-- actually,
let me come from there--
the normal is going
to look something like this.
OK.
So it would be connecting
from the origin
to that point on
the circle, and keep
going out in that direction.
That's the normal direction.
So F sub 1, if g is
a positive function,
it points in exactly the
same direction as the normal.
If g is a negative function,
it points in exactly
the opposite direction.
So F_1 would be
flipped exactly around
if g was a negative function.
So if I want to compute the
flux for part a-- I'll do it
down here-- if I want to
compute the flux, remember,
I'm taking the integral
along the curve
of F dotted with n ds.
Well, F dotted
with n is constant.
And that's the main point that's
going to make this easier.
At each point-- I guess I should
say F_1-- F_1 dotted with n
is always equal to the length of
F_1 times the length of n times
cosine of the
angle between them.
With a very quick
calculation, you
can see that winds
up being g of 1.
So the only reason I don't have
to worry about absolute value,
is if g is positive, I'm
pointing in the same direction.
If g is negative, I'm pointing
in the opposite direction.
And so the cosine theta is
minus 1 instead of plus 1.
You might want to check
that for yourself,
but this is just g of one.
So that's a constant.
So this is actually
equal to g of 1 times
the integral over C of ds.
Now, what is this?
If I integrate this, I should
pick up exactly the length
of the curve.
OK.
Because this is the
derivative of arc length,
so when I integrate
this, I get arc length.
But it's a unit circle,
so the arc length
is just the circumference
of the unit circle.
So that's 2*pi times g of 1.
OK.
And that's all you get.
That's it.
So we didn't actually have
to parametrize anything.
We just had to understand
F_1 relating to the normal.
So I didn't draw the normal
here, but if I take this normal
and I spin around
to here, the normal
is in the same
direction as F sub 1.
So now let's look at F sub 2.
And let's do this first
by pointing something out
about the relationship
between F sub 2 and F sub 1.
Notice that if I take F sub
1 and I dot it with F sub 2,
I get 0.
Right?
Because ignoring even the scalar
part, I get x times minus y,
plus y times x,
which gives me 0.
If the scalars come along
for the ride, I still get 0.
So F sub 1 and F sub
2 are orthogonal.
And in fact-- you can
do this for yourself,
but if I come over
and draw the picture,
F sub 2 is going to be F
sub 1 rotated by 90 degrees.
Something like this.
This is my F sub 2.
Again, if g of 1 was negative,
F sub 1 would be this direction,
and F sub 2 would
then be around here.
But ultimately, it's not
going to matter in this case
whether g is positive or
negative, because notice
what happens.
If I want to integrate F sub
2 dotted with the normal,
notice the normal is in the
same direction as F sub 1,
so F sub 2 dotted
with the normal is 0.
So if I'm going to integrate the
function 0 all along the curve,
I shouldn't be surprised that
my answer to part b is 0.
So there was even
less work in part b.
Because I immediately
had that F sub
2 is really in the direction
of the tangent to the curve.
And so I have something in
the direction of the tangent
dotted with something
in the direction
of the normal-- in fact,
the normal-- so I get 0.
All right.
So now I'm going to draw
a picture for c and d,
and then we're going
to use that one.
And I have to make sure
I come on this side.
Sorry about that.
So here is (0, 0).
And here is (1, 1).
Actually, you know what?
I'm going to make
it a little longer.
I might need more room.
So (1, 1) I'll make
a little further up.
OK?
(0, 0) and (1, 1),
and that's my curve.
There's (1, 1).
OK.
Now, if I parametrize
it in this direction,
then I can draw my normal.
Because it's a line
segment, my normal
is constant in its
length and direction.
So at any given point, it's
exactly equal to this vector,
up to the right scaling.
And it should be
something like [1, -1]
divided by square root 2.
That's my normal.
If you want it precisely,
that's what it is.
You don't actually need it to
solve this problem, though.
But that's what it is if
you want it precisely.
Now let's look at what
F_3 is, and then we'll
look at what F_4 actually is.
So let's look at F sub 3.
F sub 3 was the
vector 3 times [1, 1].
So if we come back
to our picture,
at any point on this curve, if
I go in the [1, 1] direction,
I stay parallel to this curve.
I don't want to draw
the whole thing,
because it would take
up the entire curve.
It's longer than
the curve itself.
But F sub 3, at any given
point, points in this direction.
So this is F sub 3, but not
as long as it actually is.
But only the direction is
going to matter in this case.
So F sub 3 is pointing
in this direction.
So if I want to compute the
flux, I dot it with the normal.
But look at what happens.
The normal is orthogonal
to F sub 3 at every point.
And so F sub 3 dotted
with the normal is 0.
And so again, for exactly
the same reason as part b,
in part c, the flux is 0.
So again, it's exactly the
same, that the vector field
I was looking at and I wanted
to compute the flux for,
is actually tangent to
the curve at every point.
And so when I dot
it to the normal
to the curve at
every point, I get 0.
And so computing the flux is 0.
So now, I have one more to
do, and that one is part d.
And in this case, F
sub 4-- let me just
remind you-- is 3 times
the vector [-1, 1].
And so if we go back
to our picture here,
F sub 4, if I compare
it to the normal,
in fact, what I
get is very long.
This is probably not
quite long enough.
But that's at least the
direction of F sub 4.
And so F sub 4 is exactly
the opposite direction
to the normal.
So if I want to compute the flux
of F sub 4 along this curve,
all I have to understand is F
sub 4 dotted with the normal
and the length of the curve.
This is exactly the same
type of solution as part a.
So let's notice this.
First, F sub 4, the
length is 3 root 2.
You can compute
that pretty quickly.
The length of n is just 1.
It's a normal.
That's why this
stuff didn't really
matter what exactly it was.
It's good to know what
direction it points in.
So F sub 4 dotted
with n is exactly
3 root 2 times cosine of the
angle between n and F sub 4.
The angle is pi.
You notice they differ
by 180 degrees, right?
So it's cosine pi,
which is minus 1.
So what I do in part d, is I'm
integrating along the curve
the constant negative
3 square root 2 ds.
This is exactly F sub 4
dotted with the normal.
And so as before, this is
going to equal to negative 3
root 2 times the arc length.
Because the integral
over the curve
ds is going to be
the arc length.
And the arc length
is very easy to see.
You've gone over 1 and up 1.
Right?
So Pythagorean theorem,
understanding right triangles,
however you want to do it, the
length of this curve is root 2.
So this works out to be negative
3 root 2 root 2, which is just
negative 6.
So let me just remind you,
there were four problems here.
There are two sets of
problems, where in each case,
you have one similar
to the other.
So let me point this out
one more time, and just
sort of step back.
We had a circle, and
then in the next part
we had a line segment.
But in the circle,
one of the problems
had the vector in the
direction of the normal,
and you wanted to compute
the flux for that.
And in the other, the vector
was tangent to the curve,
and so it was orthogonal
to the normal.
And you wanted to compute
the flux for that.
Obviously, when you're
tangent to the curve
and then orthogonal to
the normal, you get 0.
And that was the
case for b and for c.
When you're normal to the curve
and of constant length-- which
was the case actually for both a
and d-- then all you have to do
is find F dotted
with the normal,
and then find the arc length,
and multiply them together.
So that was the real strategy
we had to use for a and for d.
So hopefully, this helps you
see how the geometric quantities
are interacting to understand
the flux of a vector field
across a curve.
And that's where I'll stop.